hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Amnesia the bunker
my eyes are still a little red
um but that could be because of a lack
of sleep from running a runway for the
third months
[Music]
how's this way until the loading screens
done so where we left the man I'm having
some trouble I'm a little tired I had to
fly back um from the hospital I'm from
filming to get here and then I have to
immediately get back into things
tomorrow so we need to pick up where we
left off which I think that we were in
the vicinity of winning or something
like that I know we got a lot of codes
so I'm pretty sure oh we ran out that's
right we ran out out okay so we ran out
of gas which is not great because I know
I've been saying I have a lot but I have
a funny feeling that there's only a
limited Supply in this entire building
bunker whatever you want to call it and
uh if I run out
I highly doubt I'm gonna get any more
stairs are a problem for me
and uh we did get a little dicey with
the um
creature before and we do seem to have a
little bit of a problem with keeping
storage space we've been expanding the
inventory but we haven't been able to do
anything else let me just fill it up to
the brim and then get a plan going
before I do anything else I do like I
didn't notice it before but it auto
pulls out
and that's awfully convenient because
I'm awfully lazy I try to think of the
good things when they come all right so
we need to get to the Arsenal again
Mission storage there must be something
in the mission stores that we need and
there's something in the warden's office
that we need there's a wrench did I get
it
did I
in the workshop
wait
did I get it but did I get it did I not
get it
9th of July did I not get this
my conscience compels me now as it
failed to compel me then I must do
something even if it costs me my own
life
I must do something lest I never sleep
again
I must do something or risk greeting
hell itself as a relief
I go I I go to okay how to get the hell
out of here and wrench location note
okay
from Foreman Stafford down in
maintenance
what okay since I got some codes I'm
gonna go see about the codes first and
then I'm gonna turn around and I'm gonna
try to do something else okay that's
that's my first order of business and I
don't necessarily need to turn on the
generator to go get the I say this with
Incredible confidence blockers because
it's right nearby but
you know how it'd be oh it's tempting
fate and such
that door is broken
okay we got up first
um clemont Fortin Eau Claire or Stafford
well there's Fortin okay what is 410 is
eight four oh four got it okay eight
four oh four they're never too far off
just like real life okay we got that and
a rag uh good for a Molotov boo sale
I don't think so clemon eclair Stafford
come on okay Stafford got it oh wait I
didn't see what why was there a
heartbeat
oh
why am I so jiggly
wrench nice
nice
very nice all clear
four six
okay
all right that's good
oh
it's fine
I'm guessing that just sometimes it's at
another part of the building and and
that's good for me uh but I got the
wrench uh which is great and that means
that I'm gonna be able to
oh I should get another I should get
another torch that was very useful
um I got another fuel that's great I got
this first aid which I don't really need
because I got so much first aid I think
they're expecting me to take a little
more damage but I'm not doing it but at
the very least I have the wrench which
allows me to get into some hidey holes
that I wasn't able to get into before
first of which is I think the warden's
office had a wrenchy hidey hole so I
could go there to start and now I think
oh man where am I gonna even put
everything because I don't know if
things actually do stay if you just put
them on the ground I feel like I've put
stuff on the ground before and it's not
here again so what do I really know
wait a minute
[Music]
there's no comforting music
that drop of blood always there oh
is it down there
okay
so uh I didn't I just pick up a bullet I
thought that isn't okay that oh I gotta
hold it down all right I remember how to
play the game do you think it's down
there
okay
if you're down there you gotta tell me
right now
I don't want to do this I gotta turn on
the light if I'm gonna go this far but
I'm not gonna not turn on the light
because I'm a big baby
I'm gonna go down here that was weirdly
red
oh my God
[Applause]
oh cool
oh my God
oh
my God
if you expect me to like have some
insight or some really intelligent
commentary I don't have any right now I
got nothing
we're in the same boat of not knowing
what the hell's going on I don't know
what that racket was did you break this
thing what's the deal
I'm going for it screw this screw this
screw this screw all of this
screw this this is going for it screw
this cool okay I'm going to get uh in
the I'm going over there in the warden's
office oh my God scroll was so hard
I'm not about how quiet it is
I'm not about that
I am not about that
okay I am
I'm not okay with that oop oops
my God
that was the most uncomfortable moment
I've had in a horror game in a very long
time like
that's just not fair what is that sound
I don't know
okay that's still locked I think the
wrenchable was
around the corner
here it comes
no no
no it's nothing
oh
is this loud it sounds loud
sounds very loud and it's a little slow
okay
all right
okay update on prisoner 73014 why is
this so tense
why with the rest of the cells that
empty I begun to the program of
aggressive interrogation I hope the
screams have not kept you awake he
continues to insist that he is a common
soldier that his rank was accidentally
torn from his uniform and that he knows
nothing of the second Army's plans I do
not believe him I've ordered rations for
the next three days when next he's fed I
assume his gratitude will loosen his
tongue a final note this work would be
much easier if the officer wine rations
were loosened well isn't he so nice
oh
no
get
away oh that was all my bullets
that was all of my bullets I don't know
why I did that that was so stupid Oh my
God
foreign
how are you still alive
did I just piss myself okay so maybe not
as but I don't know if I needed to use
all my bullets
uh did I have a grenade I had a God I
had a grenade I panicked I didn't even
use it oh why didn't I bring a Molotov
or something okay well
a grenade to actually use it
oh
odd the moment that I needed it okay so
I'm willing to bet and I can't wait
around here I know that I can't just
wait around and I know there's got to be
something with this prisoner but I don't
remember what the prisoner has wait
dream of it every night what is this
I've seen it I was there in the dark I
dream of it every night now I'm at a
ritual begins with drinking a liquid
sweet and thick like mucus or honey
repulsive yet intoxicating as I drink it
warms my body fills me with a Lust For
All Things carnal sex blood flesh around
me are others their face is hidden their
bodies Rippling I know we all serve the
same Master to the same end a place in
her unending Kingdom immortality the
things I do in these dreams a terrible
world of Horrors bloody and twirled that
make the Charnel pit of War seem like
mere play Awake horrified but in the
dreams I'm elated the worst part at the
end of every day I want to be asleep I
want to go back to that place I want to
feel that way I want the violence and
the Ecstasy and the [__] black darkness
that's Lovely isn't it
um so is probably what I gotta do
shut up shut up shut up shut shut up
dude dude
thank you
okay I think he's in that back right one
but
what am I to say
I think he's in that one but
no I gotta check the map first
yeah he's in the back
second from the back right
which is great so I'm gonna open
everything except that one
all right
I don't even know why I have that out
still
okay the lights are flickering
was was it hiding
oh frick me
oh Freak Me
I'm not a coward
oh shoot better not
[Music]
oh
uh good
I'm just making decisions as fast as I
can and hopefully everything works out
for me I'm gonna fuel you better not be
down there you were just over somewhere
else so I'm
just gonna guess
oh
wait wait wait why was my vision like it
was way way wait a minute
oh my God
oh I hate this
I hate this I'm going back oh frick uh
let me actually bring one I'll save that
for later I'll put this in there because
it needs to be then I'm going for it
oh I hate this I hate this so much I'm
not about this episode I'm not about it
so is it just gonna keep hanging around
there
set the deal with this one
until I what give it the soldier or
whatever
I don't want to kill that dude he might
be my only help in this place
sure there's a language barrier but
don't we all struggle to understand one
another
okay
so it doesn't seem to be there if you
could just hush a little bit
foreign
there's fuel there
that's good that's good
oh man okay so that's definitely not a
good one to have open
[Music]
oh god
oh freak
foreign
I think that one was also a no
I didn't check that last one
oh
I see what I can do
okay
that one won't close so no matter what
ah
so I need the wire cutters I don't even
need that on there I don't even care
yeah I know
is there a hole behind you oh there's a
hole behind you anyway how is it not
gotten you if there's a hole behind you
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
open it and then I'm going to close it
and then I'm gonna get him to come over
here I'm gonna block this as much as I
can
it's pretty good oh yeah
he's never gonna get through there
in penetrable hey look a picture
okay got it
all right ready let's try this
close it
here I am buddy boy
here I am look at me
I I look at hey wait
hey wait a minute
oh he really only wants this guy
but I'll save him
you know if he wasn't so loud he
wouldn't have any problem
over here
here I am you really you son of a [__]
I just had an idea
so this lasts a while
there's only one way in
and that's through this one
so if I lead him a little farther away
yeah there he is okay here we go
go go go go open God damn it
not today dude
with that okay I'm out here yeah you
take that yeah you take that yeah what
of it yeah whatever and then he's safe
safe
did it oh [__] he mad oh [__] you mad
oh frick oh
oh I'm sorry can you not get oh [__]
you know what I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna
you know I'm just gonna
whoa can't see [__] oh boy oh god oh
and that's how you get it without
getting them killed
that's what I call good gaming I have a
funny feeling he's gonna be coming after
me for that one but um
hey
for now
I'm A-Okay sure I'm a few Panic bullets
down but hey who isn't these days let's
get our bonus Fuel and then shut her
down
okay
wow so we got um we have wire cutters
and now we have a wrench so we have
suddenly two things that we didn't have
before that are useful question mark I
don't know but I have them so that's
good
keep that because there's handy okay so
I got the wrench and I got the wire
cutters and I know that there are tons
of things to open with them but I'm not
100 sure what is a necessary thing to
progress a story and what's a necessary
thing to progress my pockets
so I didn't get the soldiers quarters I
could go in there I suppose
okay let's try that at least I'll cover
my bases I know there's probably stuff
in this Zone that I'm in right now that
has
unlockables with these things I just
don't know what they are but if I'm
going to be carrying these then I have
like I just don't have enough in my
pockets to be able to do anything else
so I gotta go try to expand my pocket so
I'm gonna go soldiers quarters first
try to open that up was that unlocked
did I
ah well I'm not known for my
intelligence
although I should be with how well I
played that last one
again it's still flickering and I don't
know if that just means that the whole
thing is kind of the infrastructure's
crumbling or if that actually something
incredibly bad that I should be aware of
is that my blood
oh boy
foreign
oh my God
okay
oh no oh frick oh God no it's weird
which way should I go oh that yeah okay
yeah
I'll come back
[Music]
okay
well this is clear now
oh [__] oh freak
oh frick
Frick I thought this might be the way
around
man I just want to get into this room
but I don't know how
is there a music playing
is there supposed to be music playing
oh
hi rats how do I get into this thing
I thought that would be a more elegant
way to get into this thing
do I gotta blow this door okay I can do
that maybe there's no I don't even have
bullets to be able to do the barrel
trick okay I'll be back
I might be able to burn it down but I
have no idea honestly
and that was a big waste of fuel well
that's terrible
was that him was that him uh emerging
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God
don't do it
I'm not even gonna hang around and find
out not even gonna hang around not even
gonna do it and I'm not gonna entertain
the idea of hanging around
because I don't want to
all right let's blow this joint oh hey
more stuff great
okay fire in the hole
I'm quick oh I'm not quick enough
that's a problem
foreign
[Music]
yep that's bad oh God
it's a good thing I'm really smart
and very fast
and really good at wasting gas
well that's not fair
now see I feel like this is just a
little unfair
good
oh no
of course there's nothing
serious oh that is actually helpful but
wait a minute I have a code for one of
those names that I oh 7085 because
clamon
what is that noise
is in the left like back left up the
stairs and back left over there so there
must be a code over there to be able to
open
great to know I already got that
this gently
oh gently gent gentle giant
ly all right
demo
is not here for lemon
I mean this is helpful but the clamor
what are you hardened
why would you have a card
lemon
is a broom a secret
it is
I don't see anything for clever
I see your hearts I see a lot of rats
I'm out of here
okay
so I didn't need the wrench or the wire
cutters for either of those and I didn't
get a bag expansion
so how about that truly
a travesty
a real blow to morale
oh
clemon was here the whole time
7085 I just missed it before
bullet bullet
can note
picture hey isn't that oh yeah that's me
oh look at me and look at lamper don't
look there's something else I'm off with
Lambert I don't know what's going on
there
uh no 8th of July mid-afternoon yeah
this is a good time to read this the
Scout for tonight routine Patrol
out to the communication wires and back
it'll be cloudy good cover easiest
Patrol possible Sergeant wants me or
augustan to go
you still suspect one of us might have
been with the mutineers but I won't be
going
but how can I be so sure well Augustana
has agreed to a friendly game of chance
to determine which of us it will be and
using an old sleight of hand trick
there's no way I'll lose oh no augustan
doesn't have a chance because I'll
ensure he doesn't
mean right a scoundra
perhaps but when he returns and I remind
him of the time he pissed in my flask or
the mysterious lies that appeared in my
bunk or the incident with that bar made
well I laughed in those cases and he'll
laugh in this one right of course is
that why you feel so terrible
scoundrel
I call scoundrel
[__] I forgot it was nearby
oh he's pissed at me oh
right
lamby
[Music]
you need not be so pissed
it was all a prank
it was just a prank bro
don't go in this one please
oh
well that's not gonna help if y'all
pop your head in here but at the very
least if the powers doesn't go out then
it won't emerge at random I guess
man this is uh bad
hey that was a nice
it's a nice okay you know what I'm
actually gonna ration a bit because
um you do get bonus if it's halfway
through it'll round up
we'll round up which is good to know
gotta go pick up more bottles and I
gotta dump more of these because I just
don't need them I'm just gonna drop them
I guess yeah
all right I'm just gonna drop them I
don't think I need it
to restock my bullet
Wham and I'm not gonna be so reckless
this time with them one one bullet to
stun it and then run away that's what I
gotta do that's the only thing forward
I'm gonna do real quick is I'm gonna
check the surroundings
to see if there's some uh boltables or
old cuttables or anything like that
because I think I remember seeing
something uh let me check down this
hallway because I think there were other
rooms down here
maybe there's something
a whole lot of nothing actually
Reynard how do I get in raynard's room
secret passageway between bunks
good doll
nah all right it's probably got to be
blown open and I don't see any
explosives nearby got a gas canister but
that's I don't think it's going to cut
it I think I need to go down to the
maintenance tunnels no I need to go to
the Arsenal there's got to be something
in maintenance that needs me to open it
boom
perfect
I knew I did this for a reason quiet
perfect so sneaky a lot of bottles that
are
I mean if I I guess I could make more
things LaRue reports that no yay is the
source of the problem he's going around
telling the men that these damn texts
contain amounts counts of pagan rituals
performed in those tunnels ghastly and
wild stories now Superstition and rumors
are passed around among the men like an
open flask or venereal disease some even
say they've seen the things ghost demons
fairies instead of the angel of mons I'm
afraid we have the devil's I've called
them
I'll make sure
meanwhile the ends on us okay
man this Sergeant Raynard sure was a
winner
has left this tunnel project in Ruins at
approximately 23 but it was quickly
determined that the explosives were
missing from the Arsenal and the
explosion no accident Swift
investigation the following have come
past
four of the guilty now Rotten cells
awaiting tribunal the fists remains
unaccounted for he may have been killed
in the blast worse than double agents
these men are cowards they scream about
ghosts and demons in other worlds they
clean committed this act of treason to
save their fellow soldiers from Hell
utter nonsense we're still working to
clear the tunnel side assess the damage
but I fear any hope of using them for
our purposes is now lost in addition the
explosion has caused other structural
damage to the bunker yeah flooding is
now occurred in various areas great
good that is so many bottles
so are these full or something I mean I
guess it was The Wine Cellar so
they're all empty which I guess it means
I can make more of the you knows well
it's not exactly what I was hoping for
well at least I always have a steady
supply
well
so I'm not going that way turns out if
you're quiet if you're generally not
clunking around sprinting you can get
away with a lot you're you're not safe I
wouldn't say but uh the odds are more in
your favor I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
ahead and fill it up take advantage of
the bonus come on give me the bonus
oh [__] I'm gonna lose the bonus no the
bonus no
come on what are you doing
oh it's not gonna bonus me
ah well I got a little bit of a bonus
like a two percent that's just as good
as anything else all right I'm gonna go
to uh
uh the
I'm gonna go to the Arsenal
um and I'm gonna see about this tunnel
and then if I can blow this thing wide
open I am free I think all right I don't
exactly know what I'm looking for but I
know that there are tunnels down here
somewhere
this could be blown open
yeah
no other way in
what was that did I just hear a voice
also can I burn it down use I'm trying
there's no way okay so the tunnels would
be oh never mind you can crawl I can
crawl
ah
okay
good to know
and then I can cut that that's good to
know
okay so I I needed these for this
that's good
so now that's there and there's flooding
great
that's good oh is this like a mini
generator
come on now
all right there might be some kind of
transition to get this one connected to
the something or other that doesn't look
good and I have this strange
familiar feeling about Amnesia and water
uh-huh
uh
oh no no no no
oh no
they put then they knew
they knew they're not gonna put anything
here they want the Vibes to get you but
the Vibes aren't gonna get me
it's gonna take a whole lot of more
Vibes to get me than this will
I've been through this
a few times
what was that
is this gonna electrocute me I hope so
okay
oh God
truly terrible
what am I supposed to do about this
can I actually get this out of there
seems like I might be able to it's
moving a bit it's like right there but I
can't quite get it to ongo I'm gonna
guess no I'm gonna guess that's not
coming out
I probably have to blow it up oh is this
on now oh oh is this a pump
ah it's a pump
oh that makes a lot more sense
right
thank you
all right well that's good
okay any goodies revealed from that
nope I can only hope that when I beat
this game it's gonna like give me a
unlock item that's like a mini gun and I
can just come back here and wreak
vengeance
you know what I mean
just a little bit of havoc
get out of here
okay oh my God really
holy [__] oh I'm gonna glitch through
the walls if you keep that up
all right wow it's dark
good thing I got my gun
oh freaking maze huh
all right
more water yeah
foreign
I wasn't sure with the other Splish
splashes I was here and I wasn't sure
what was going on
could have been anything
holy [__] look at that
what is that about
what are you doing there wow yeah I
would love to do that
I would love to do that are you about to
give that to me
oh
let's see what this was about had to see
what the dark held had to oh no all of
them they don't have the right kind of
eyes there's a world down here full of
seductions and secrets and my eyes are
right for it never mind that they
trapped me down here I have seen a
vision a vision of a gone World bloody
and terrible beautiful and awful Godly
and infernal All Around Me voices the
past clawing spinning whirling I don't
know what they do I don't know what they
want have to stop it can't see it
anymore it tasks me with what I do not
know please God above if you were ever
there and this give me some way to end
it
I see it now I see it now see it now see
not see it now see it not whirling and
whirling and whirling
calls for blood oh this is that too song
guy he didn't die in the explosion yeah
[Music]
all right
wow
that's good job kind of like my eyes
anyway look at this